you see the hat i am mrs
nesbit snap out of it
are you still trying to digest all the
content disney announced at their
investor day we did an entire episode on
their upcoming star wars shows and still
got blindsided by the book of boba fett
so we feel your pain
after running through the marvel and
star wars news we're still hanging in
there to break down the rest of disney's
upcoming slate right here on the ketchup
fans were given their first clue into
what they beyond in two infinity and
beyond might look like with the pixar
prequel
lightyear tentatively scheduled for june
2022 lightyear will focus on the origins
of tim allen's buzz lightyear action
figure specifically the real-life space
explorer voiced by chris evans that the
toy story character was modeled after
though we didn't see any original
footage from the angus mclean directed
project
promotional material hints at a mix of
the familiar and brand new buzz
we'll be seeing the origins of the
heroic space ranger as he works to
protect the galaxy but should expect our
hero's personality just like his voice
to be slightly different than the one
we've come to know during the course of
the toy story films which shouldn't be a
problem considering fans equally love
every entry in this franchise a stranger
from the outside
but the expanded fun doesn't stop at
lightyear because disney also announced
seven series that we'll be able to
stream on disney plus four of which will
expand the stories of characters we
already know and love
like remember that big marshmallow puff
of a medical robot from big hero 6
well now free to perform his actual
functions as a nurse spy
audiences can look forward to following
baymax in his new self-titled series as
he explores san fransokyo finding new
friends and patients to help
sometime in early 2022. helmed by the
movie's director don hall
baymax is the second spin-off of the
popular franchise following 2017's big
hero 6 tv series which ran for three
seasons on disney xd
but who cares about the superhero kids
give the lovable robot his own show
i will scare you now scan complete
meanwhile get ready for some meta
programming from the zootopia universe
which explores fan favorite characters
by making them the stars of their own
fictional reality shows catch series
like so you think you can prance
and life at slot speed in 2022's
zootopia
plus which you can find on disney plus
see what they did there
bingo pretty sneaky slick
additionally two disney princesses will
also be getting their own original
series that we'll be able to stream on
disney plus
picking up where the princess and the
frog left off 2022's tiana follows
disney animation's first black heroine
as she adjusts to life as royalty in new
orleans is french quarter
the following year brings us moana which
focuses on the lore surrounding the
pacific islands that gave us the beloved
maui from the original film
and i imagine this is disney plus to
audiences right now what can i say
except you're welcome do you love disney
but just hate animation first of all
seek help maybe but also disney has you
guys covered in this department
as well don't worry first up is a new
sister axe sequel
rumors have been circulating for years
about a follow-up to 1992's non-centric
blockbuster and its sequel back in the
habit but now for the first time disney
is confirming
not only the green light but the return
of star whoopie goberg
as dolores van carter a singer on the
run from the mob who goes into hiding at
a convent
although we don't yet have a release
date tyler perry is confirmed to produce
for disney plus the latest installment
of a now 20 year old franchise and i
think it's safe to say
that i will follow him
and finally disenchanted will see amy
adams back as giselle in the
long-awaited sequel to 2007's enchanted
so far there are few other details
regarding the release date or returning
cast but the follow-up to the
post-modern fairy tale about a
soon-to-be princess
cast out of her cartoon kingdom of
andalasia and banished to real-life
manhattan was originally slated for a
2011 release
so right now fans are just happy to hear
that this film is happening at all
signaling potential further delays
disenchanted director adam shankman's
hocus pocus sequel was also revealed to
be in production during investor day
meaning we may have to wait just a
little bit longer to find out what
happily ever after actually looks like
for giselle and her friends
i'm angry i'm angry all right it is time
to throw it over to you now what are
your thoughts on all these upcoming
disney shows let us know in the comments
section and of course if you want more
movie and streaming news
head on over to rottentomatoes.com and
don't forget to check out our brand new
rotten tomatoes is wrong a podcast from
rotten tomatoes because fresher run is
just the beginning of the conversation
and new episodes drop
every thursday and if you don't miss out
on any future episodes of this show be
sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification
bell and as always we can't thank you
enough for watching to catch up my name
is az perez
signing out with my famous catchphrase
to infinity and beyond
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you